welcome back we're here with Lucy hail
and Nat wolf talking about all things
relationships okay oh gosh here we go
grab yeah that's perfect Lucy there you
go
okay
okay what's one thing more people should
be doing on first dates asking questions
I feel like do you ever feel this way
when you're on a date you are are you
are you single or in someone I am I am
single and and this is a good time to
propose okay I'll propose
to
okaying I just the three of
us well we're getting
married of course um asking
questions people don't ask questions
couldn't agree more Nat as a last oh
oh have have you ever told a pretty
little Li to a l so Lucy hail was on a
show called Pretty Little Liars this was
back in the good old days and we met one
time on a carpet and uh we had like kind
of a flirty moment and so then she
tweeted about me at 2 in the morning 2
in the morning what's with n wolf might
be the cutest this is a true story you
and this was like the most exciting
moment in in the world for me and then
cut to like 10 years later I'm on a hike
and I see Lucy and I wave to her
thinking she thinks I'm the cutest and I
wave to her I go Lucy Lucy and she go
takes off her headphone looks at go is
true okay and then just starts walking
no and starts walking past and the thing
so then Lucy told me that that didn't
happen and that was the pretty little
lie that she okay got it got it Lucy I
love and that's why we're getting
married married not M Lucy hail their
new film which brings me to you it's in
theaters everywhere tomorrow we make
this show for you so take it with you
and your loved one